Simplifica 3
por la raíz principal de "500x" cúbica,
y lo que vamos a hacer aquí,
es separar lo que está adentro del radical,
en los términos que son cuadrados perfectos
y que podemos extraer del radical
y lo demás, lo que sobre,
lo dejaremos dentro del radical,
también hay que recordar que
cuando nos referimos a la raíz principal, este,
signo de radical aquí,
nos referimos a la raíz cuadrada positiva de un número,
veamos entonces
si podemos separar "500x" cúbica,
en algo que sea cuadrado perfecto
y algo que no va a ser cuadrado perfecto...
pues para empezar ni 500 ni "x" cúbica
son cuadrados perfectos,
Cuando haya duda empiezas a sacar
factores primos de esto,
para poder encontrar aquellos factores
que son cuadrados perfectos,
entonces 500 lo podemos factorizar
como 5 por 100
y aquí
podríamos ver que 100 ya es el cuadro perfecto,
es 10 al cuadrado,
pero si no notáramos eso,
podemos seguir extrayendo,
factores 100 es 2 por 50
50 es la multiplicación de 2 por 25
y 25 la multiplicación de 5 por 5
y aquí es donde ya podemos ver,
que aquí tenemos 2 por 2,
tenemos 2 al cuadrado,
y aquí tenemos,
5 por 5,
5 al cuadrado,
100 es 10 por 10 ó
2 al cuadrado por 5 al cuadrado
de cualquiera de las dos maneras
puedes separar esto,
y "x"cúbica...
"x" cúbica, se puede separar...
"x" cúbica que tenemos aquí,
claramente lo podemos separar como,
"x" cuadrada por "x".
Hemos separado "x" cúbica,
en algo que es un cuadrado perfecto
y algo que no es un cuadrado perfecto,
reescribamos entonces este término
que está dentro del radical,
esto es igual a 3
por la raíz... voy a dejar un espacio aquí
3 por la raíz de 500,
que puedo escribir como
5 por 100,
y 100 que es el cuadro perfecto de 10,
100,
lo puedo escribir como
10 al cuadrado,
no tengo que hacer esto que hicimos aquí,
pero esto te ayudaría a reconocer que esto es,
4 por 25
los dos son cuadrados perfectos,
así que esto es igual a 3
por la raíz de 10 al cuadrado
por 5,
500 es 10 al cuadrado por 5,
éste de aquí lo escribimos como
10 al cuadrado por 5
y "x" cúbica
"x" cúbica que puede escribir como
"x" cuadrada por "x"...
"x" cuadrada por "x"
y déjame extender el signo radical hasta acá...
y esto es lo mismo que,
usando las propiedades básicas de los exponentes, porque bueno cuando estamos tomando una raíz,
estamos aplicando propiedades
de exponentes fraccionarios,
así es que esto de aquí es lo mismo,
esto es igual a 3,
por la raíz principal de 10 al cuadrado.
Déjame hacerlo así con este color...
por la raíz principal de 5,
por la raíz principal de "x" cuadrada
y por la raíz principal de "x".
Y ahora podemos simplificar esto como...
aquí tenemos la raíz principal de 100 que es 10,
10 de la raíz principal de 100
-10 también es raíz de 100
pero estamos solo tomando la raíz principal,
así es que la raíz principal de 100 es 10,
5 no es un cuadro perfecto así es que dejamos
este término simplemente como la raíz cuadrada de 5,
ahora x cuadrada.
Aquí mucha gente...
tú estarías tentado a decir, bueno la raíz de "x" cuadrada
es simplemente "x",
¡pero no! mucha atención,
pero
¿qué pasaría si "x" es un valor negativo?
supongamos que "x" es un valor negativo,
por ejemplo,
supongamos que "x" es igual a -2,
entonces al elevar "x" al cuadrado,
esto nos va a dar
4 y aquí la raíz de "x" cuadrada,
la raíz principal de 4 esto es 2,
pero si hubiéramos tomado el valor de "x"
estaríamos tomando el valor de -2,
pero como tenemos la raíz principal,
tenemos que tomar el valor de "x"
con signo positivo, es decir,
sin importarnos si "x"
es positivo o negativo,
para la raíz principal,
siempre queremos la "x" con signo positivo,
esto es entonces,
el valor absoluto de "x".
Esa es la cualidad de la raíz principal
y ahora, esto se simplifica,
recuerda que como estamos aquí
multiplicando una serie de expresiones,
no importa en qué orden tomamos el producto
podemos ordenarlos de tal manera que
primero tomamos los términos que tienen radical,
y posteriormente,
los términos que no tienen radical,
tenemos entonces,
3 por 10
por el valor absoluto de "x",
esto es 3 por 10
que es igual a 30,
30 por el valor lo absoluto de "x"...
30 por el valor absoluto de "x"...
y esto,
multiplicado por raíz cuadrada de 5
y por
raíz cuadrada de "x"...
y aquí tenemos la raíz principal,
la raíz cuadrada de 5 por la raíz cuadrada de "x",
esto lo podemos escribir como,
la raíz cuadrada de "5x".
Aquí tienes el producto de dos cosas
elevada a la misma potencia fraccionaria
es lo mismo que tomar primero el producto
y después elevar todo eso
a la potencia fraccionaria...
potencia fraccionario o sacar raíz cuadrada,
así es que esto,
se simplifica finalmente como 30,
por el valor absoluto de "x"
por la raíz cuadrada de "5x".